hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast real-time profiling of tumor
heterogeneity and metastatic disease and
Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted supremely this educational web
seminar presented by labyrinth and
sponsored by epic sciences epic sciences
Philips new highly sensitive diagnostic
tests that identify and molecular ly
characterized circulating tumor cells
ctcs any blood to provide a better way
to detect cancer and personalize and
monitor treatments for more information
visit epic Sciences com we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the events you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button to the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation wyndham or
submit your problem through the Q&A
button the green one green given a
button floor left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker mark Landers
mark Landers has been I'm sorry Marc
Landry says 18 years of experience
developing molecular assays with
extensive experience in qpcr microarray
and NGS cafe development in both
research and regulated environments he
has led the commercialization of several
microarray qpcr and NGS based assays for
biomarker discovery in his current
position as director of genomics at epic
Sciences is leading the development of
assays to characterize cpcs using
genomic end points including qrt-pcr and
NGS prior to tenure at epic mark was
head of R&D at Alfea idx where he
developed several companion app days for
targeted therapies he has also held
several senior level scientists
positions in San Diego I hope community
accompanies including life
oh jeez Sarah Jean and Baikal I will now
turn it over to mark Flanders for his
presentation thanks Judy and thanks to
all the participants today for joining
us the focus of this talk is tumor
heterogeneity and no static metastatic
patients so during this webinar will
first review the concept of tumor
heterogeneity and the use of circulating
tumor cells to profile heterogeneity and
metastatic disease we'll give you some
background on the epic technology
platform and its key differentiating
factors to detect and characterize these
heterogeneous CTC populations and most
importantly will show you some of the
heterogeneity we see in late-stage
metastatic patients and we'll use a data
from a cohort of metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
patients so before I do that let me give
you a little background on epic sciences
epic sciences our mission is to improve
patient lives by enabling precision
medicine with non-invasive real-time
tests that can profile rare cells in
cancer simply put using our proprietary
CTC platform to better characterize a
patient's disease characterized the sub
clonal diversity present prior to and
throughout the course of therapy
allowing us to tailor more accurate and
efficacious therapies so epic was
founded in 2008 it's a SAN diego-based
company that we're up to a hundred and
seventeen employees now now shown in the
bottom left is a picture of our 40,000
square-foot facility in San Diego we
have a fully licensed CLIA lab that we
can use to run these assays and support
of clinical trials and we're in the
process of developing IVD instant
instrumentation for diagnostic purposes
so currently we offer the epic
technology as a service in our land
and we currently have over twenty six
partners Pharma partners and sixteen
academic partners we have contracted
over fifty to analyze over fifteen
thousand samples and have participated
in 45 clinical trials across 12
different cancer types we have developed
45 different protein immunofluorescent
assays targeting different molecular
targets we've developed a lot of DNA
fish assays targeting GNA DNA
rearrangements that can be targeted in
individual CTCs we're developing our RNA
fish capabilities and most recently
we've developed NGS capabilities to do
next-gen sequencing on single cells to
profile genome-wide copy number
variation so this is a diagram of the
drug development cycle and how epic can
use its platform to work with our farm
of partners throughout the entire
process so to develop a phase early on
we can help our farmer partners to
develop assays for observational trials
where we are looking to better
characterize pharmacodynamics mechanism
of action mechanism of resistance and
identify markers that could potentially
be used for CDX applications companion
diagnostic applications we can take
those assays and qualify them in
validating and run them in our CLIA lab
prospectively for patient selection to
support interventional clinical trials
and then moving forward we're developing
the capabilities to for diagnostic
applications where we could use this to
for both companion and novel diagnostic
therapy selection and monitoring of drug
resistance so we really think one of the
most exciting applications is of this
technology is real-time monitoring of
disease resistance or drug resistance
and seen those emergence of resistant
clonal populations
so one of the biggest problems facing
precision medicine today as tumor
heterogeneity and it's it's a negative
effect on therapeutic efficacy and so
cancer is a heterogeneous disease
there's been a lot of native that
heterogeneous both in patients to
patient comparisons within a single
cohort we have a lot of different
drivers and tumors of the same tumor
type as well as within a single tumor we
have lots of sub clonal populations of
cells that potentially have different
genomic drivers or different phenotypic
features that make it very difficult to
for drug development and patient
stratification when you're starting from
traditional tumor biopsies this was a
paper published recently this was a
Charlie swatton's group where they
looked at they wanted to further
investigate inter tumor heterogeneity
and the sub clonal diversity within
tumor samples so they went in and mind
TCGA data from 2,700 approximately
single tumor samples across nine major
cancer types and they took the variants
that were called the single nucleotide
variants as well as the copy number
alterations that were called and based
on their allelic frequency or the
fraction of the mutant allele in the
sample that could define it as clonal or
subclone and then they could further
characterize the relationship of those
mutations as being earlier late and
designate them as either clonal or sub
clonal drivers of disease and so some of
the important findings of this study
where that there were frequent
observations of sub clonal drivers
present in every tumor type they looked
at so sub sub clonal populations that
have a that have different drivers
within a single patient if you look at
this figure shown here on the right each
column represents a different tumor type
that they looked at it's shown in each
row our therapeutic
relevant gene targets that are often
used to select therapies or in stratify
patients what you can see here are in
highlighted in blue are the areas are
the samples the the genes in which there
were significant high frequency of sub
carmen'll populations in those samples
so does was there a lot of heterogeneity
in the targetable mutations within these
different tumor types and the answer was
yes and one of the main conclusions that
they drew from this study was the need
to stratify targeted therapy response
according to the proportion of tumor
cells which have the driver and moreover
to go even further and let the
proportion of tumor cells that have an
alteration within a particular pathway
that might be druggable so there's been
a lot of other reports showing that
intratumoral heterogeneity can have a
negative effect on the efficacy of
targeted therapies this was a
publication from 2013 this was a whole
exome sequencing of 149 CLL patient
samples they did both variant lifted
single nucleotide variants as well as
copy number variants and based on the
relative abundance of the mutant allele
in the sample they were able to
categorize these as either clonal or sub
clonal and then they were able to
compare that across the patient
populations and in in respect to
response to the therapeutic as well and
so the interesting take home from this
message in the upper left hand corner
you can see the average number of
mutations per sample that were detected
either sub clonal and blue or a clonal
and orange so there were more sub clonal
alterations detected in patients that
had received previous treatment versus
the patients that were treatment-naive
and that was a statistically significant
difference and so if you take those
patient populations and you don't and
you stratify them by yes
with sub clonal populations present and
that's shown in the dark green line on
this capital marker or there were
subcloned drivers there were no sub
clonal drivers detected the light green
line on the kaplan-meier occurred and
you make two separate distinct
populations and stratify based on just
sub clonal drivers you can see that the
time to therapy failure was much shorter
for those with sub final sub clonal
alterations present so this in summary
you could just think that the more
heterogeneity you observe the worst of
therapeutic response so another
interesting study is we know that
there's tumor heterogeneity there was a
paper published in 2013 and this was a
study to look at the ctc s could reflect
the sub clonal diversity that we see in
the tumor population and so this is a
pilot study they did and they used up
cameron rich dtcs as well as primary
tumor biopsies and metastatic tumor
biopsies and they did whole exome
sequencing and so here what they wanted
to see is could they identify sub clonal
alterations in the tumor samples that
were reflected in the CTCs and so the
alterations shown here on the right and
the top is the primary tumor and in the
middle is the metastatic tumor and then
the individual CTCs that were sequenced
are shown below in the mutations that
are highlighted in red those are the
alterations that are common to all three
they were in the primary they were in
the metastatic and they were in the
CPC's and these can be considered early
driver alterations whereas if you look
in the blue in the those were specific
to just the metastatic tumor biopsies as
well as in the CTCs and then if you look
at the black mutations that were
highlighted there they what those are
specific to CTCs and so they didn't find
those originally in the metastatic or
primary tumor biopsy however they went
back and they resample
they receipts and they were able to find
low sub clonal populations of cells
without mutation and either the
metastatic or primary tumors so you know
it really speaks to the fact that you
can use CTCs to monitor some clonal
heterogeneity at even very low levels
and they do reflect the active
metastatic population so it also
highlighted the power of single cell
sequencing and being able to look at
single ctcs and this I couldn't resist
putting this in here this is a slide
that Levi Garraway presented at a ACR
this year and it's really just an
analogy of comparing the analysis of
single CTCs versus doing more bulk
approaches of either pooled CTC
populations cell-free DNA or starting
from say a tumor biopsy so if we really
want to understand the diversity of
clonal populations if you look on the
left I can characterize each one of
these and I can get a much better idea
to their relative proportions what their
characteristics are and I can monitor
those sub clonal populations if i mix
them all up and and then try to decipher
which populations are there it makes it
much harder and so at this point i think
i'm going to switch back to to reviewing
the epic technology platform and why we
think it has some key differentiators
that allow it to differentiate it from
other technology platforms for the
analysis of ctcs and allow us to look at
more heterogeneity and so how does it
work how does the epic analysis work so
starting from patient samples so this is
showing you our epic lab in San Diego so
in our lab core partners in either
Belgium or Singapore so blood is taken
at the clinical site and it can be
shipped to any of these three
destinations for north american and
American trials blood is taken in a 10
ml tube shipped to our San Diego
location at ambient room temperature
shipping conditions and the most
processed for LabCorp in in Belgium and
Singapore too if you're in Europe you
can do the same process however they
will just do the first stage of the
process to get the samples to a stable
stopping point and I'll show you more
about that in a second so this is kind
of a diagram of what the process is and
so blood is received at the laboratory
and we it's processed so if the 10 ml
tube of blood is processed where we lie
saw the red blood cells and then we
pellet out all the nucleated cells in
and resourced in them and then place
them on to replicate slides and so these
are proprietary slides that help us get
an even monolayer of about 3 million
cells per slide from a single tube we
can make 12 slides and then these slides
are stable at this point can be stored
at minus 80 and so this is where our lab
prayer partners stop and they can now
ship us those samples and they're very
stable for shipment and for subsequent
analysis so now we can go into our minus
80 freezer and we can pull out our two
two slides per assays typically what we
use but you could do more or less we
pull out two slides and then we want to
identify the ctc so we use a cocktail of
immunofluorescent antibody staining
targeting cytokeratins cd45 and Daffy's
so cd45 is specific to the blood cells
cytokeratins are specific definite
dealio so and Daffy tells us which cells
have intact nuclei we also have an open
channel which we can mix in a fourth
marker so an example of this I'll show
you a greater detail some examples
different examples but just so you have
a good
Prince point we can mix in if we're
working in prostate cancer we would
typically target the androgen receptor
or if we were working in breast cancer
we could at her too or a are so after we
do the staining for these different
molecular markers we can then scan the
slides and take the images and so after
scanning the images are processed and we
don't only look at the molecular markers
we have a proprietary algorithm that
looks at cells pretty much the way a
pathologist as it was trained by
pathologists and so we we look at a lot
of cell morphological features that help
drive the identification of cells that
are different in a field of 3 million
white blood cells so by measuring these
morphological features and integrating
that with the molecular markers we can
then come up with candidates etcs that
are then confirmed by trained operators
here and those are generated into a
report so why is this strategy so
different and enable us to see so much
more clonal diversity than other
platforms and so there are the majority
of other platforms on the market rely on
some sort of physical enrichment
strategy to separate the circulating
tumor cells from the contaminating white
blood cells and so you know most of
these are relied on a epic am enrichment
or uck to enrich but basically
antibodies targeting cell surface
markers that are specific to circulating
tumor cells or or the filter by size
which can make the assumption that
circulating tumor cells are always going
to be bigger than white blood cells and
so all these proaches have the same
similar issues where you're going to
have CTCs that don't necessarily have
epithelial markers presented on the
surface or you're going to have CT sees
that can look at that look about the
size of white blood cells and will blow
right through a filtration device and so
the key differentiating factor of the
epic platform is that we look at all
nucleated cells within the sample and so
there's been a lot of reports recently
about an epic and positive fkm negative
cells circulating tumor cells and when
we see these cells we can tell that
they're also expressing a biomarker of
interest and I'll go into a little bit
more of what these look like but I think
this is what allows us to see the
increased clonal diversity present and
metastatic patients so this is what it
looks like this is an epic slide and we
can zoom in and you can see what the
what a field of cells would look like
and so you see all of our white blood
cells around that can be used as
controls and then you can see our rare
cell right there in the middle and so
for each test we analyzed about 6
million cells to identify the rare cells
in the population and we use a variety a
multitude of morphological and molecular
parameters as we previously described
but the key things to take home at this
point are no enrichment so we're not
manipulating the cells we're not losing
any epithelial plastic cells and we're
not losing any smaller CTCs and so we
see a larger range of CTC subtypes so so
we wanted to show you kind of some
images of what those might look like and
why they're important and so if you look
here this is showing you what our normal
controls look like this is all the white
blood cells that we see within a patient
population that Daffy nucleus and
they're positive for cd45 the rare cells
that we find some are traditional CTCs
so these are traditional CTCs with
epithelial markers that are expressing
ck they have an intact nucleus and these
are CTCs that would probably be detected
by a lot of other platforms however we
see a larger diversity than that we see
a lot of small ctc so these are state
pcs that have epithelial markers
sometimes they're have cancer gino's
however they're just much smaller
they're approaching the size of white
blood cell
we also have the ability to detect a pop
tonic CTCs where we see that the nucleus
is no longer intact but we can also
count these as a you know a farmer
pharmacodynamic in point so here's an
example of CTC that is in prostate
cancer and this is a CTC that is no
longer it's become epithelial plastic
it's no longer expressing cytokeratins
but it's still expressing its androgen
receptor very brightly and when we
sequence these genomes we can tell that
these are actually cancer genomes and we
can really see that these would be cells
that would completely be missed by most
enrichment based methods so there are a
lot of other morphological features that
help us further characterize the CTC so
we can look at very detailed
morphologies we can see the speckling of
cytokeratin we can look for macro
nucleoli which could be associated with
nuclear instability we could also look
for clusters and so this is a big
advantage we can detect clusters not
only of traditional CTCs we can detect
clusters small cell clusters ck minus
clusters clusters of macro nucleoli and
we can further characterize these and
there's been a lot of recent
publications showing that CTC clusters
have been associated with an increase in
metastatic potential and associated with
poor prognosis so there's a wide range
of integrated analysis beyond just BTC
enumeration we have a variety of protein
markers that we can use to further
characterize these cells to there could
be potential biomarkers and so we'll go
through the list or a example list of
different protein markers that can be
used but the key point here is that all
these influence can be used together in
an integrated analysis and not only are
we looking at the cell morphology
whether markers it has a
surfers we can do further detailed
analysis looking at gene amplifications
by fish where we're looking at DNA
arrangements this is your alch we can
look at Pete in-laws we're starting to
get online or RNA fish to be able to
look at the expression of specific
transcripts in our cpcs by are like fish
and more recently we've started
developing our genomics capabilities to
where we can go in and isolate
particular CTCs of interest recover them
and analyze their genomes for copy
number alterations genome-wide as well
as targeted mutation panels and so that
integrating all these endpoints together
gives us further resolution to be able
to define distinct sub clonal
populations and here's some examples of
some of the assays this is certainly not
a completely comprehensive list but just
to give you an idea of some of the
protein assays we've developed genomic
assays we've developed and what we're
working on we have protein acids that
target some very interesting targets and
prostate cancer we have a are targeted
protein assays that target both ends of
the AR protein we also have a targets
towards PSM a PSA we have PDL one which
is a particularly important marker and
immunotherapy we can target incoherent
expression on the cell surface which is
a common T marker or we can look for
genomic rearrangements which are
associated with tumor suppressor loss or
uncle genesis like Pete in Los her to
alch most recently we launched a whole
genome sequencing copy number variation
essay and this is doing low-pass whole
genome sequencing to look genome-wide
for tumor suppressor loss or el cajon
gain and so this allows us to look at
identify sub clonal populations by
genotype and then we can integrate that
information
with our protein analysis and phenotypic
analysis we're working on launching some
assays that target the ARB 7 so this is
a transcript and I'll show you some data
on this later in the talk we also have
new fish acids that can target a Ruark a
RB we also have we're working on
developing targeted resequencing panels
so looking at therapeutically relevant
point mutations within the genomes of
our CPCs so taking single cells and
monitoring actionable mutations and the
sub clonal populations and we're also
developing qrt-pcr targeted gene
expression so looking at small gene
panels starting from single cells and
we're rapidly developing that so that at
this point I just want to remind you the
key advantages to the epic platform are
you know enrichment free ctc analysis as
well as integrated phenotypic molecular
and genomic profiling and these allow us
to paint a really distinct picture of
the clonal diversity that's present
prior to and throughout the patient's
treatment so we also have the ability to
bio Bank samples which is for subsequent
analysis which becomes even more
important because as you bank these
samples and new biomarkers become
interesting you have the ability to go
back to these samples later for
subsequent analysis so this is where
we're going to dive into the data and so
I think we're going to start by looking
at a rv7 expression in metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
patient samples but before we do that I
just want to show some data that was
presented last year from the Johns
Hopkins and where they looked at a RV 7
as a predictive marker for resistance to
a are targeted therapy and CTCs so this
was data they generated by f cam
enrichment
cease from whole blood in a pooled pool
in a pooled CTC sample they then lysed
eyes open and look for the armv7
transcripts by qrt-pcr so the the
presence of the qrt of the v7
transcription and gold the patients that
are positive for that can be associated
with poor response to the therapeutic
and resistance to a are targeted
therapies and so shown on the left is a
waterfall plot and way to read these is
that when the lines go up that's the PSA
level going up after treatment and so
these patients continue to resist
therapy if they have if their PSA goes
up if the line goes down then you can
see that the PSA is decreasing the
therapy therapy with somewhat effective
and work to decrease their PSA so these
samples were taken at baseline they
looked for the air v7 transcript and
then they looked to see if those
patients then responded or didn't
respond and you can see that the assay
is very specific to the patient's air v7
was mostly detected in patients who
resisted either enzalutamide on the left
or abiraterone on the right they are
targeted therapy and this makes sense
because their v7 doesn't have the
doesn't contain the domain and either of
these drugs target so we wanted to look
at a single cell last day taking our an
ARV seven antibody and then further
characterizing aren't the CTCs we see
for the expression of a re seven
actually in the nucleus of our epic CTCs
so this is work we did in conjunction
with Memorial sloan-kettering and Howard
cheers group and this is a we took 60
baseline blood samples from patients
prior to their treatment with either a
our targeted therapies or chemotherapy
with taxanes patients were we took
baseline samples prior to first line
second line or third line treatments
and then the patient response was
measured by their PSA pattern did the
PSA just go up following treatment or
did the PIAT did they show some initial
response to PSA and so before we get to
the association with the arv 7
expression in response I think is
important to point out the wide variety
of biological range of ctcs that we see
a rv7 expression in so we can see that a
rv7 protein is expressed in CKD positive
CTC ck minus CTCs and CTC clusters so
this is some a lot of these cells would
be missed if we did up cam enrichment
and looked at just for a rv7 expression
so we really feel like the single-cell
resolution and are the larger range of
ctcs we concede can paint a better
picture of the true clonality of cells
expressing every seven in resistant
patients and this is data is showing the
the frequency of a rv7 CTCs within
patients and so shown here in the
Beehive plot on top are the relative
number of the CTCs detected that were
expressing armv7 in the nucleus in
patients that were sensitive to a are
targeted therapy and the patients that
were resistance targeted therapy shown
on the right is the similar curve for
patients that were either sensitive to
taxanes or resistant to taxanes and the
key take-home message here is that we
only detected a rv7 protein in the
nucleus in CT seized from patients that
were resistant to a our targeted
therapies we didn't detect any in the
CTCs from patients that were sensitive
to a [ __ ] therapies however when we
looked at taxanes we detected in both
resistant and sensitive patients but
that doesn't really paint the picture of
true coronal heterogeneity and what we
want to see here is
can look at the relative proportion of
cells that have a RV set that are
expressed in the v7 in the nucleus
versus those that are expressed not
expressing v7 and so that's what the bar
chart on the right is showing patience
each bar represents a patient patients
were looking at a RV 7 CT sees the
number that were quantitated and so
we're looking at first line patients
then second line and third line moving
from left to right and so what should
jump out at you is that the large
heterogeneity of a rv7 expression in the
CPC's and if you go further and you look
at just the percentage of a RV 7 CTCs
that are shown in the table below you
can see that in second line and third
line patients the percent of ctcs
expressing a RV 7 can range anywhere
from 17 up to seventy nine percent of
the CTCs so clearly clearly there is a
RV 7 being expressed in the CTCs but
however there is there are sub clonal
populations and so it's important to
have that kind of resolution to be able
to figure out what's really driving the
disease and so as I mentioned before we
look at phenotypic features in our CTCs
than the help us further characterized
the sub normal population so we have
phenotypic measurements that we take and
I think we went through that but this is
the process for better characterizing
the CTC phenotypes so we have after the
slides of them scanned we do we can
further analyze the image and this is
the the digital pathology algorithm that
we've developed it will segment the
cells and start collecting a lot of data
about the cell size the cell shape
nuclear artifacts that it measures a lot
of ratios and I'll go through these all
in a little more detail but the point is
that we can really get a detailed
picture of what the cells look like and
after all seeing is believing so we can
merge up the phenotypic data
our molecular markers that are expressed
on the surface and and so going back a
step these are some of the measurements
that we take on each cell so we look at
the nuclear area nuclear convex area
look at the circularity what the nucleus
looks like what does the daffy staining
look like is their nuclear speckling or
the macro nucleoli so clearly we're
looking at a lot of different features
here and this is going to paint a much
more detailed picture of what the clone
allottee looks like so to demonstrate
the utility of this we wanted to look at
each one of these features and see if we
could come up with distinct phenotypic
profiles for CTCs and so we took 151
patient samples which had about 9,400
some CTCs from patients at baseline
second line or third line therapy and we
can take these our measurements we made
of the different cell phenotypes and
characteristics and we can do some
principal component analysis to see
which phenotypic features cluster
together and so that shown here is a
five by five plot showing how these
different features cluster and are
interrelated but the take-home is that
this clustering can identify 15 unique
CTC phenotypes and now we have a
specific phenotypic subtype of ctcs that
we can go in and count so back to that
end we have you know we wanted to
measure what are all the different types
of phenotypic subtypes of ctcs that are
present in patient samples and so shown
here are we were discussing those 15
phenotypic categories so these are
different cell types and moving each
column is a is a different patient and
where you see red that's a high number
of those cells and where you see why
that's we didn't detect any of these
cells and so you can see that there's a
lot of different phenotypic cell types
present in each patient and it's pretty
hard to get a
gasps fun is so one of the things we did
is to look at use a measurement of
overall heterogeneity and that's what's
shown on top we used a measurement
called the Shannon index and this is
something that colleges use when they go
into rainforest to characterize the
diversity of the different animals they
see in the rainforest as a measurement
of how ecologically healthy the
environment is and so you look at the
Shannon index of the different sub types
of ctcs we see by phenotype this tells
us how many different subtypes are
present and what's the relative
heterogeneity within a patient and so if
you look at this they're ranked from low
heterogeneity to hire heterogeneity at
first line in blue second line in green
and third line in red we have some
patients who are well beyond third line
treatment and we also segregated them
into their own bucket but what's
interesting about this is that there's a
lot of heterogeneity that exists
regardless of the line of therapy so
this isn't just a result of therapeutic
intervention and and so we can draw a
cutoff and say this is what we're
defining is high heterogeneity and
that's the dotted lines shown above and
we say okay if these patients are
considered extremely high heterogeneity
and the other patients are considered
lower heterogeneity how does that relate
to their response to therapy and so this
is segregating those two patient
populations high heterogeneity shown in
the red and blue being the low
heterogeneity population and we can look
at the relative time on drug and so this
means the time until they had to they
fail the drug so when the therapy
stopped working and so you can see a
statistically significant difference in
those two patient populations in their
response to therapy and in general the
patients with lower heterogeneity were
on drugs for 5.7 months longer that's a
pretty significant odds ratio of 11
six so this is really highlights the
fact that heterogeneity it also
corroborates what we presented earlier
where they had shown that higher
heterogeneity influences and negatively
responds to targeted therapies and so
when you look at higher heterogeneity in
response to a are targeted therapy and
again these are showing the waterfall
plots of PSA measurements after
treatment and so this is showing that
their best PSA response and when you see
the lines go up that means they didn't
respond PSA continued to increase and
they were resisting therapy and when you
see the lines go down the therapy had
some effect and we reduced the PSA
levels so when you look in the AR
targeted therapy cohort shown up top you
can see our highly heterogeneous
patients shown in red clearly cluster
together in the resistant category but
when you look at response to taxanes you
can see that the highly heterogeneous
patients both responded and resisted
therapy so this really speaks to the
fact that understanding the sub clonal
heterogeneity prior to and throughout
the treatment with targeted therapies is
critical so CTC heterogeneity we wanted
to further defining so we've looked at
protein and morphology and we want to
integrate all these together we also can
look at genomic heterogeneity and this
was a study this is data from a study
where with one of our first
collaborators Genentech and I see are
where we wanted to look at what is the
most reflective measure of the
metastatic population so if we take a
bone biopsy from metastatic
castrate-resistant patients and we
characterize it 4 p-10 status what's
more reflective of the current
metastatic state of the patient sample
is it the CTC blood sample can we get a
better accurate description of
metastases in the blood sample or would
it be better to go back to a primary
archive tumor sample and so we had each
of these for each one of the patients
and they were all analyzed independently
and so we looked at peach in status and
in the CTC as you can see that the p10
status we found p10 loss and we also
found normal peach in cells within
patients within the bone metastatic
sample we also saw similar heterozygous
loss and normal wild-type p10 status as
well however within the primary tumor
sample we saw predominantly the p10
normal so this really says that peach
and loss was a sub clonal driver that
happened later in tumor progression and
if we were to base our therapy on this
we would and we looked at the bone
biopsy we would say that the patient's
al-jabal for pi3k inhibitor if we were
to say look at the CTCs we would also
give him that same inhibitor however if
we were to go back to a primary tumor
sample he would not be eligible for the
pi3k inhibitor so I think this really
speaks to the fact that the CTCs are
really reflective of sub clonal
heterogeneity and really reflect the
active metastatic sub clonal populations
and so when we look further into the
CTCs that we've seen in these patients
but you can see here each column
represents a the percent of ctcs with a
particular p10 status so p10 loss is
shown in maroon p10 heterozygous beaten
moss is shown in gold and p10 loss our
peach and wild-type is shown in gray and
so we look across the patient cohort you
can see that even when we see p10 loss
that's still a sub clonal population
when we see Pete in heterozygous loss
that's still a sub clonal population so
really speaks to the power
looking at single cells and
understanding the relative proportions
of cells that are actively metastatic
with a particular tumor suppressor loss
if we look at how well the CT sees would
mash that would match up and predict the
p10 status of the fresh to bone biopsy
the positive predictive value was
seventy nine percent whereas if we look
at the how well the archival tumor
sample would predict the p10 status of
the bone biopsy then we would see that
the positive predictive value drops
considerably to fifty three percent so
this is again confirming that we're
really the CPC's are reflective of the
active metastatic operation so something
we're working on now and we developed
and launched in the earlier part of the
year was it NGS based assay to globally
profile genomic alterations across the
whole genome so this is a we isolate
single CTCs we can then do low-pass
whole genome sequencing and then we can
look at tumor suppressor or uncle gene
copy number alterations across the
entire genome so we can then take those
copy number profiles and we can cluster
them together in very distinct clonal
populations and then because we look at
cell morphology as well as protein and
molecular markers we can collate all
that data together to come up with very
distinct sub clonal populations and then
track those throughout the course of
treatment so to look at this clinically
we looked at 350 CTCs across 17 separate
patient samples these are patients who
again were either resistant to a are
targeted therapy or responsive or
resistant to taxing therapy or
responsive so this is an example of some
of the typical data that we see and
shown on the right our copy number
profiles of each CTC and what's really
cool here as you can see that the copy
number of profiles paired up with the
actual image of the cell so you can look
it's kind of hard to see on these slides
that you can actually correlate what the
cells look like and to what their
genomic has profiles look like so we're
actually starting to to be able to look
at vina phenotype to genotype
associations and so what jumps out of
you when you look at these two distinct
patient examples is on the left is a
responder this guy is responding to a
are targeted therapies there's very
little clonal diversity he has you know
mostly a single or maybe potentially two
different clonal populations however
they're relatively flat and copy number
alteration when you look at the patient
on the right we see that you can detect
a larger number of distinct clonal
populations by clustering and wherever
you see red is our areas where we see
deletions and wherever you see green are
areas where we see amplifications so
when you look at each CTC you can see
there's some common drivers associated
with this the clustering of these cells
together in different populations and a
particular interest if you look over to
the right on the very right hand side
you can see each one of these cells
almost all of the cells in this patient
had an amplification of the AR gene and
so this is an early alteration that was
very early and so if we looked at this
in a heterogeneous population we would
say it must be AR amplification that's
driving disease however when we look at
the different sub clonal populations we
can find different subpopulations that
have different tumor suppressor loss
around getting gain and to show you that
across the entire 17 patients tested you
can we've broken up the patients by
either resistance on top and the blue
where we look at either a our targeted
therapy resistance or taxane resistance
or on the bottom patients responding
they are targeted there
p or resisting text responding to
taxanes and we've looked at how many
across all the CTCs which percent of the
CTCs had some Arnold populations of
these different tumor suppressors loss
or pocketing amplifications that have
often been associated with prostate
cancer disease progression and so
interestingly enough you can see that
the majority of sub clonal heterogeneity
is in the resistant patient and if we
look at particular alterations we can
see that not only does the patient have
AR amplification he also has loss of RB
bracket to an ATM loss so there's a lot
of interesting subtotal late alterations
that are happening they could
potentially be driving that Colonel
differentiation if we only looked in
heterogeneous populations where we would
just pool all these cells we would lose
a lot of the resolution to see this so I
think at this point we wanted to wrap it
up and I'll just kind of go through and
summarize a lot of the points that were
previously made so enter tumor
heterogeneity is frequently observed
across multiple tumor types I think that
was the swanton paper clearly says that
as well as other types of other sources
we have increased heterogeneity
definitely has a negative effect on
targeted therapies and therapeutic
response and so this's was been cited by
others as well as observed in our own
data the CTCs are truly reflective of
the sub clonal populations and the
active metastatic sub clonal populations
and the epic platforms unbiased approach
allows us to see a lot more a wider
biological range of ctcs and integrating
these molecular phenotypic and genotypic
assays gives us the capability to really
identify distinct sub clonal populations
that we can in target actionable markers
to strata better stratify patients
metastatic disease and so at that wraps
it up and so I think at this point we
will open it up to questions and so
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session we'd
like to ask you a couple of poll
questions the first one is I am
currently evaluating technologies that
will enable need to utilize a liquid
biopsy in cancer evaluation yes or no
you going to answer that one okay and
I'll just get a little ahead here and
app mention the next one the next one is
would you like to be contacted by one of
our technical team to discuss your
project yes or no I'd like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green two and a button at the
lower left of the presentation window we
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question is how does
this technology detecting and analyzing
CPC compared to CF DNA it's a great
question so you know both technologies
both cell-free and looking at CTCs have
strengths and can have some clinical
utility however that being said the the
DNA that you're looking at in cell-free
DNA is largely the cells that are dying
and so when you know there's some
distinct differences that I think are
important when you're when you're
treating a patient you want to see the
emergence of resisting chorim's those
are not the cells that are actively
being targeted and
right also there's a there's a distinct
advantage to single cell approaches
where we actually retain information of
the cell of origin so are we looking at
a single cell with multiple mutations in
a single pathway are we looking at
multiple sub clonal populations with
individual mutations in different
pathways this is going to change how we
prescribe targeted therapies because we
will if we're targeting particular
pathways we need to know what the clonal
population is that is defective in that
pathway and then finally when you I
think that one of the big differences is
thinking back to that example of the
individual fruits all in a mix versus
the kind of fruit smoothie that we saw
where you can see that when you
homogenize all these cells together you
lose sensitivity to see copy number
alterations because now you're going to
see a lot of cells like in our case of
our p10 study there's a heterogeneous
population of cells that have peach and
loss or is there's a lot of stuff but
didn't have the p10 loss so I think you
know you would lose the resolution to
see that and that's potentially relevant
therapeutic target epic performs GF DNA
test as well as your CTC analysis on a
shame sample yeah absolutely i think an
epic we're we really own the sample you
know we get our sample in we're
currently in the taking and a lot of
studies we take a sample off the top to
isolate cell-free DNA from before we
process them with our standard assay
this gives us the flexibility to pull it
and do comparative analysis but also to
look for you know actionable markers
within the cell free DNA that might
direct patient treatment what other
genomic assays kinetic perform besides
sandy so we're currently in the process
of developing hotspot mutational
NGS essays and we also have a the
capability to run qpcr for specific
point mutations there's a lot of great
qpcr tests that measure a single
nucleotide variant like Cheerios or egfr
but we also have the ability to look at
thousands of these mutations together in
a single targeted resequencing pool and
we still retain the single-cell
resolution so we can look at how many
cells within a particular patient are
harboring you know a t790m resistance
mutation throughout the course of
treatment with a TK I can you provide a
list of cafe and biomarkers you can test
for absolutely so I think we're happy to
follow up with anyone and provide a full
list and I think the information shown
here on the screen you can just email
for information at epic and we'll follow
up with you to give you a more detailed
list of the different assays we can
offer and how we can work with you to
better characterize your samples when
will be I need the instrument you
mentioned be available so i think we're
targeting next year i can have there's
probably a more detailed plan that I'd
be happy to have some of our business
development associates follow up with
you but we are currently in the process
of IBD development and and that is
ongoing and we're hoping to have that
pieces of that platform really soon have
you compared the number of ctcs as it
identifies with other ctc in rich new
platform yeah that's um that's a good
question and one we get all the time so
we currently you know the the FDA
cleared sav the verra dex cell search
assay were used for ctc enumeration we
constantly do
comparisons versus that essay although
we're we're really doing a different
process where we're actually
characterizing themselves and in much
more detail of rather than just
enumerate them but when we do just the
comparisons of enumeration and a
side-by-side setting we consistently
detect more CT sees and this goes back
to the enrichment free analysis so we're
not discarding any cpcs based on
physical properties such as another
epithelial marker expression and if next
when I take two parter have you seen a
correlation between CPC heterogeneity
and tumor progression or does the CPC
population tends to be more or less
heterogeneous in patients with
aggressive cancers yeah that's a good
question and and I think there is a
correlation between CPC heterogeneity
and tumor progression versus the
targeted therapies and I think we showed
some data showing that when when there
was higher heterogeneity of different
sub clonal populations there that they
responded more poorly to therapy and we
also have you know there is also would
be happy also to follow up with you
offline if that's to give you more
information about those associations how
did you pick your single CPC for
sequencing and are they fixed Phil on
slide yeah so that's a great question so
we do this single cell isolation
following our standard standard epic
process so we the blood comes in it gets
deposited on cells are on slides then we
record while we're skin the XY
coordinates of every single cell so then
we can go back to the slide after we've
scanned and character
is helping morphological and molecular
markers on those cells and recover those
CTCs we have a unique process for doing
that so it's a but it drives basically
it's an automated or semi-automated
process where we go and we can recover
the CTC then it is dropped into a single
well of a PCR plate and then we have
single cell isolated in a single well
and we can proceed with genomic analysis
like we have time for one more question
have you ever been used this platform to
itself is healthy normal sample yeah so
we routinely run that as a control that
is that's a great question we routinely
run healthy donor samples as a control
and this is a we don't see circulating
tumor cells in these samples so you know
we whenever we get healthy donor blood
we do a lot of spike recovery samples
and we do not see a lot of circulating
or any circulating tumor cells in most
of these samples okay turns out we have
time for a couple more so what is the
fraction of single cells ctcs that yield
valuable NGS data low pass Xi'an Zhi
that's a good question so recently in a
study I think we were our success rate
is is upwards of ninety percent from the
cells we targeted to pick versus the
cells that we get cute QC profiles that
pass our library complexity as well as
our sequencing qcs so we're about ninety
percent ninety-five percent success rate
okay can you do RNA a phase as well as
the DNA ones yeah it's a great question
so currently we're developing are
several RNA asses so we have RNA fish
that we're currently developing
targeting several transcripts and we
have a few assays that are starting to
get
through the development cycle we're also
in the process of developing small
targeted digital gene expression you
know using qpcr so we're looking at can
we do I soak in a single cell and look
for the relative expression of six seven
eight genes from a single cell and so
the early data and development we're
having some success with it and we think
the early data looks positive but we're
still in development with that
capability okay last question today what
is the depth of sequencing needed for
CPC's or primary metastatic samples for
clone allottee and subclone allergy so
to detect the in the primary tumor
sample most of the reports that were
shown here the sequencing depths were
upwards of 500 x to the texas up clonal
population so they really sequence very
deeply especially in the patient and
that colorectal example where they
sequence the primary tumor they actually
had to go back to it and sequence deeper
to get the detection to be able to
detect those sub clonal variants with
the CTCs we don't have two sequences
deeply because we're we're doing the
analysis from a single cell however we
do have to make sure that we get uniform
coverage over the areas we're trying to
profile so currently in our cm VSA we
get about point 1 x coverage across the
genome so it's low-pass whole genome for
targeted resequencing applications we
can shoot for a 50x coverage just to
even out all the different the
uniformity of coverage across the
different regions of interest well thank
you sorry we have run out of time we'll
follow up with you on questions we did
not get to today in the next couple of
days I'd like to thank our sponsor epic
Sciences for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing from
December of this year you'll receive an
email from lab roots alerting you when
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues may have
missed today's live
and see you next time bye